yes she broke up the perfect score
possibilities
uh and leaves only one leader at 2-0
making congratulations i want to know
are you upset that their game has lasted
longer than your 94 moves
no i'm used to being the last board so
it's good to
be the second to last
this is your first championship uh you
lost against irina yesterday wasn't
exactly a great struggle but today it
was a titanic struggle your feelings
about finally winning
um
yeah i think in the opening she played
um bishop c4 i think i prepared for
bishop's b5 which
um
i think she usually goes um so i wasn't
super prepared but i think i got a good
position out of the opening and was able
to win
i'm sure it wasn't that easy you just
had a good position on the opening it
seemed like there were so many stages to
that game so many tricks to overcome but
one thing we've noted is in the last few
months it seems like your rating has
really skyrocketed have you been
studying a lot of chess or is the
performances have started to come
together
i haven't been a lot i've been working a
lot full time
so it's
i think this is the first over the board
tournament i've played in over two years
so
i've just been playing online mostly and
as you feel that has helped you
um i think i tried to play only blitz
like five minutes or more
so
i think some of that slow chess has
translated a little bit how do you feel
how did you feel when you got the call
to be able to play in this tournament uh
i was really excited it's always been a
dream of mine to play in this tournament
so to finally come here to the
chess capital of the world it's really
exciting yeah well good job today and
good luck in the rest of your games
thanks
if you don't mind me asking megan
where for you was the moment you kind of
said
i got this game because it did have so
many lives and it just did seem like it
was such a titanic fight where where did
you finally think
uh i i i've got this game in the back
like was it after e6 or
where
where was sorry to interrupt you guys
sorry big big moment in this game here
okay before we go g5 was played
g5 queen f3 gf6 looks like uh we're
going towards a draw in this game he did
get the pawn here queen takes bishop d4
not playable he wishes he can do the
pitch trying but you can't make the move
and it looks like we are now quickly
ending this one in a draw as well but
continue and that
yeah they're going to make a repetition
so i'm just asking uh when did you feel
and i'll get to a crucial moment
somewhere around here did you feel that
at this moment you were you're winning
or um yeah i thought when i could cover
with queen f6 it was pretty solid uh i
was
i saw e6 and then
f takes e6 and then there's like a nice
tactic with rick takes g3 in case she
tried to suck on h8
which moment was that i'm sorry i think
a little before after e6 f takes e6 i
thought she might try some tricks like
rick h8 check and then
right uh try to infiltrate but i think
before with the king on g1 there was
rook takes g3 yes and the queen on b6 um
and then i could play uh rick g8 i think
eric g7
right
it was somewhere right here when she did
play the move e6 by the way did you when
you played the queen b6 were you
confident that you were winning
because you've got the dual threats
counter play yeah but it got a little
tricky i think with the time scramble it
sure did yeah all right good luck in the
rest of your games thank you go huskies
lovely and finally